wir haben hier ja schon öfter darüber
berichtet christa klaß 9 gilt als das
neue wunderwerk zeug in der
gentechnologie jetzt hat ein
chinesisches forschungsteam gezeigt dass
die gen scherrer aber noch mehr kann als
bislang angenommen ihr fazit sie eignet
sich nicht nur für feinarbeiten sondern
auch als krasse abrissbirne konkret
konnte das forschungsteam mit ihrer
hilfe in mozambique tatsächlich gezielt
einzelne komplette chromosomen
ausschalten wie das genau funktioniert
hat und ob sich mit dieser methode schon
bald auch krankheiten wie das down
syndrom behandeln lassen könnten jetzt
in klicks um science-fiction herzlich
willkommen
mit der so genannten küsst barkas neuen
technologie kurz christa lassen sich
ausgewählte gene einfügen ausschalten
oder auch umschreiben und zwar sehr
einfach es funktioniert ganz simpel wie
eine schere mit ihr kann die dna also
das erbgut ziemlich effektiv verändert
werden und bislang wurde indigenen
schere tatsächlich nur dafür eingesetzt
erbgut zu korrigieren einzelne gene
auszuschalten oder neue erbgut stücke
einzufügen wir haben ja schon öfter
darüber berichtet doch jetzt hat ein
forschungsteam der peking university auf
ein neues eindrucksvoll gezeigt dass
diese technologie viele bereiche der
wissenschaft der medizin und ja
vielleicht sogar die welt wie wir sie
kennen revolutionieren könnte in ihrem
versuch haben die chinesen nämlich
gezeigt dass das gen werkzeug auch
anders kann statt der gewohnten
feinarbeit gab es jetzt ein regelrechtes
gemetzel und ja es grenzt schon an eine
sensation denn dem forschungsteam ist es
gelungen ein komplettes chromosomen im
wahrsten sinne des wortes zu
pulverisieren zurück zu ihrem experiment
das sie an mäusen durchgeführt hatten in
40 prozent in denen die gene aktiv wurde
gelang es das y-chromosom der
nervenzellen von mäusen föten im
mutterleib zu eliminieren
dazu einer der beteiligten forscher
koyang die christopher kas 9 vermittelte
zielgerichtete chromosomen eliminierung
bietet einen neuen ansatz um eine
therapeutische strategie für android die
erkrankungen mit zusätzlichen
chromosomen zu entwickeln damit gemeint
sind krankheiten wie das klinefelter
syndrom bei dem ein zusätzliches
x-chromosomen vorlegt das sogenannte xy
y syndrom oder eben das relativ weit
vorn
down syndrom weltweit haben etwa fünf
millionen menschen diese erkrankung alle
drei minuten kommt ein baby mit down
syndrom zur welt ihr habt es vielleicht
mal im biologieunterricht mitbekommen
beim down syndrom liegt das chromosom 21
drei statt zwei mal vor in der
medizinischen fachsprache bezeichnet man
das eben als analogie also eine
genmutation bei der zusätzlich zum
üblichen chromosomensatz weitere
chromosomen vorhanden sind ich hoffe ich
habe es richtig ausgesprochen
die medizin ist mittlerweile soweit dass
ab der neunten schwangerschaftswoche
festzustellen dann kann die
schwangerschaft abgebrochen werden ja
bislang gibt es keine möglichkeit die
erkrankung noch mutterleib zu behandeln
doch das experiment aus china macht
tatsächlich hoffnung dass dies demnächst
möglich sein könnte vielleicht sogar
während der schwangerschaft division mit
hilfe einer gentherapie überzählige
chromosomen gezielt entfernt
dieses ergebnis ist also tatsächlich ein
absoluter hinhörer und vielleicht sogar
der anfang eines neuen zeitalters doch
realistisch gesehen ist diese methodik
noch nicht wirklich bereit für die
praxis denn es gibt zu viele schnitte an
stellen die so ganz und gar nicht
gewollt sind nicht vorstellbar was
passieren würde wenn in einem lebenden
organismus die falschen chromosomen
zerstört würden zudem ist die effizienz
mit einer erfolgsquote von 40 prozent
bisher noch viel zu gering wenn ihr kein
video zu diesem thema und auch zu allen
anderen themen verpassen wollt dann
drückt mir hier ein abo aufs auge
vergesst nicht den genau auf die glocke
nur dann werdet ihr auch immer über neue
videos informiert hier geht es weiter
mit dafür unbedingt draufklicken doktor
frankenstein wird realität da geht es um
die gene von alten mammuts sehr
spannendes thema ansonsten bis dann
bleibt dran